this is a super interesting short clip I
want to play for you Rhonda McDaniel the
head of the RNC the Republican National
Committee she appeared on Fox news
earlier today and fox host Stuart Barney
was asking her about the potential
management by the RNC of the Trump
DeSantis primary that might be coming
but it might not we don't know and Rana
descent this uh Ronald McDaniel Rana
DeSantis Ronald McDaniel straight up
admits that she has no control over the
that primary and one of the things I've
talked about is how damaging to the
eventual Republican nominee will a
really ugly primary be I think to some
degree a really ugly primary will hurt
whoever comes out on top and faces the
Democratic nominee uh Ronald McDaniel
admits this is beyond her to control it
and then she does a little what about
ISM how are you going to manage this
clash between Trump and the status
Stuart I would be lying if I said I'm
going to be able to manage this there's
going to be sharp elbows there'll be a a
heated primary process what I will say
is we have to keep our eyes on the prize
we need to remember that 70 000 people
just died of overdoses our border is
open Crime is up we of course the border
is not open Crime overall is down and
it's significantly higher as we just
talked about in red States and red
cities our energy is up inflation is
killing middle income family gas prices
have come down significantly inflation
is at its lowest point since 2021.
and this is coming under the Biden
Administration so we can have a heated
primary but at the end of the day we
have to come together if we're going to
beat Biden and that's where I'm going to
be as RNC chair always focusing on the
end game which is winning the White
House and that's really the question she
is right about that at the end of the
day the question is how does the
Republican Party defeat Joe Biden or
whoever is the Democratic nominee
remember officially we still don't know
who the Democratic nominee will be
that's the fundamental question at the
end of the day and my question is
if DeSantis got out of the way it would
become obvious Trump will be the nominee
does that help the Republican primary by
allowing Trump to start campaigning now
in some way
I don't know if Trump were to be
indicted four times and drop out and it
becomes clear DeSantis is the leader or
at least that there's going to be a
contested primary not involving Trump is
that a better Republican primary for the
purposes of Republicans ultimately
winning in November of 2024. my instinct
is that a very ugly Republican primary
will dissuade some Republican voters
from coming out in November of 24 but
I don't know how big that impact will be
so my question to you is let me know in
a comment send an email send a tweet
however you want to get in touch
does the Republican nominee whoever it
will be benefit more from an easy and
smooth primary win or an ugly and
extended and contested primary win let
me know what you think we'll do a
follow-up soon based on people's
reaction we'll take a very quick break
and be back with much more